il est temps de se parler de l'iPhone 15
pro Max qui vient remplacer l'iPhone 14
pro Max qui lui-même avait remplacé
l'iPhone 13 enfin bref on s'en fout on
se parle aujourd'hui du dernier gros
modèle d'Apple dernier gros modèle qui
est juste ici alors l'iPhone 15 pro max
c'est un smartphone qui est intéressant
parce que bien souvent quand on regarde
les iPhones on se dit tiens il ressemble
vraiment à l'iPhone de l'année dernière
il a le même look and feel à peu près la
même idée si vous comparez par rapport à
l'iPhone 14 pro max globalement il se
ressemble un petit peu pour autant il y
a vachement de choses qui ont changé il
a plein de nouveautés c'est super
intéressant donc je vous donner mon
retour vous dire ce que je pense de cet
iPhone qui est bien ce qui est moins
bien ce qui marche qui marche pas un peu
de tous les côtés première chose c'est
celui-là on se parle de l'iPhone 15
iPhone 15 plus dans quelques jours donc
ça c'est une autre histoire pensez à
vous abonner comme ça on en parle un peu
plus tard on se concentre aujourd'hui
sur le Prom Max qui est le plus gros
modèle qui est aussi un modèle hyper
canon et super intéressant pourquoi pour
plusieurs raisons déjà lorsque vous le
regardez effectivement on a le même look
and F de ce qu'on avait sur autre iPhone
dire qu'un iPhone ça reste un iPhone et
c'est l'idée de toute façon des équipes
de team cookci de vous dire un iPhone
reste un iPhone pour autant il y a plein
de nouveautés la première chose à savoir
vous avez dû le voir si vous avez
regardé un peu la kyot si vous va
regarder les nouveautés c'est tout ce
contour en titane que vous allez avoir
l'idée c'est d'apporter plus de
résistance surtout de venir gagner en
poids par rapport à la concurrence avec
des smartphones de plus en plus léger il
est évident que sur un 15 pro max c'est
un gros smartphone c'est pas là on va
avoir énormément de légèreté pour autant
pour autant on passe de 240 g avec ce
modèle l'année dernière à 221 g avec
celui-là alors ça reste quand même assez
lourd c'est un smartphone qui est
imposant mais croyez-moi on gagne quand
même en PO ça c'est pas mal donc ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
qui est intéressant c'est que on garde
toujours ce dos en ver mat qui est
derrière qui prend pas trop les traces
de doigts qui est très sympa on a
toujours le céramic shield à l'avant qui
fonctionne bien et qui est très cool
donc pas de souci là-dessus donc on a un
smartphone qui est résistant qui est
beau donc en terme de design mis à part
le titane sur le côté on se dirait pas
grandchose deu non non non non non non
il y a une vraie grosse nouveauté et
pensez à venir protéger votre iPhone 15
pro max d'ailleurs vos iPhones en règle
générale et tous vos smartphones en
règle général j'ai des coques de mon
partenaire rinochid alors regardez c'est
super cool parce que rinoiel m'a
fabriqué une coque monsieur Greux ça
c'est la solide suite monsieur Greux
dans lequelle je vais pouvoir venir
poser mon iPhone et ça vient l'pouser
bien évidemment parfaitement c'est
extrêmement résistant et j'adore le look
alors il y a vraiment un truc qui est
très cool avec rinoched c'est que vous
pouvez venir totalement personnaliser
vos coques ici des solides suite alors
les solid suite elles existent dans
différentes couleurs on les a ici pour
les iPhone 15 pro me semble-t-il voyez
il y a plein plein de différents allez
jeter un coup d'œil sur le lien que je
vous mets dans la description vous
verrez il y en a énormément et ça ça
c'est vachement cool ils ont également
énormément de collaborations ils ont des
collaborations avec Marvel One Piece
Assassin's Creed la NBA winnie the Po
Disney Pixar Dragon Ball Z Snoopy Harry
Potter j'en passe les meilleurs il y en
a énormément ça c'est quand même
vachement bien ils ont également les
clear co transparentes qui sont
également venus me personnaliser et ça
aussi c'est très très chouette ce qui
fait que hop je peux la prendre poser
mon iphone dedans et là j'ai un iphone
coq transparent clear totalement
personnalisé ici ça c'est super beau
également petit détail chezinochi
aujourd'hui en plus qui est tout nouveau
qui est super bien c'est qu'ils ont une
petite structure à l'intérieur en forme
de bouclier qui vient rappeler le logo
rind Shel donc ça aussi c'est un petit
clin d'œil et c'est très sympa on se
parle i de coqu monomatériaux grâce à
l'utilisation de technique novatrices
qui r se procéder facilement et
intégralement recyclable tout en
réduisant la quantité de matière
premièrre nécessairire à la fabrication
une fois de plus on a et l'autre point
qui est génial c'est qu'ils ont une
puissance magnétique qui est deux fois
supérieure au standard de Max safe vous
pouvez notamment le voir sur la nouvelle
gourde Rino shield où vous avez ici une
accroche maxsfe pour venir poser votre
smartphone je prends mon iphone je viens
le poser ici et ça tient vachement bien
grâce à maxsfe je peux le bouger ça
c'est cool c'est rassurant alors vous le
savez chez rinochi il y a énormément de
produits je vous ai présenté la solid
suite il y a la clear il y a également
la modenx et comme ces nouveaux
smartphones sont en usbc rinoi également
des câbles en usbc d'une longueur de 2 M
qui vous permettra d'aller un peu plus
loin si vous avez bonne distance alors
il existe comme ça en tressé avec une
très jolie finition peu sur le noir peu
grisé vous l'avez également en blanc
mais il y a également plein d'autres
produits chez rinoield notamment des
coqu pour vos Airpod çairpod on en parle
très très prochainement également pour
votre Apple watch vous avez des
bracelets pour Apple watch juste
topissim vous avez également des
protections d'écran antichoc antilumière
bleue des protection d'objectifs photo
mais également des lamères de téléphone
ou encore dragon bref des produits il y
en a énormément pour venir protéger
votre smartphone mais pas que une fois
de plus je vous mets le lien juste en
bas dans la description et pourquoi pas
en protégeant votre smartphone pensez à
le personnaliser personnellement je
trouve ça vachement joli il y a une
vraie grosse nouveauté et elle se situe
ici sur le côté ça c'est le bouton
d'action ça veut dire que on passe de
l'année dernière du petit bouton qu'on
avait d'ailleurs depuis des années très
très longtemps qu'on a chez Apple du
bouton o on venait switcher pour avoir
le mode silencieux et le mode sonnerie à
un petit bouton d'action qui est
intéressant pourquoi parce qu'en fait on
peut l'attribuer soit effectivement en
étant comme l'année dernière à savoir
bah j'appuie dessus tac je suis en
silencieux je laisse appuyer longtemps
paf je passe en sonnerie on voit tout ça
avec dynamic Island dynamic Island c'est
joli c'est sympa ça marche bien donc ça
c'est le premier truc ça vraiment très
très cool et très pratique ensuite il y
a ch qui vient d'arriver vous allez dans
vos réglages et là vous venez vraiment
attribuer ce que vous voulez à ce bouton
d'action parce qu'on est pas obligé de
le garder que pour ça à savoir que vous
arrivez dessus et là vous choisissez
alors par défaut on est là et on peut
venir ensuite switcher mode
Concentration vous venez choisir le mode
Concentration que vous voulez moi je
serai plus repos par exemple qui est ici
je switch par exemple le soir au lieu
d'aller dans mes paramètres essayer ça
je viens appuyer là hop là désactiver
hop je laisse appuyer activé donc comme
ça le soir je suis assez pénard donc je
trouve ça assez malin ensuite vous avez
appareil photo vous choisissez ce que
vous vous voulez avoir soit de la photo
selfie vidéo portrait portrait en selfie
ok ça marche la lampe torche de la même
manière les Mém vocau si on va
enregistrer tac tac un peu dictaphone en
mode médecin je dicte mon compte-rendu
ok si on veut de la loupe et puis des
raccourcis donc une fois de plus je
trouve ça assez malin vous choisissez ce
que vous voulez vos favoris pour des
appels téléphoniques un minuteur des
applications bref on peut faire
vachement de choses et ça c'est cool
vous choisissez aussi l'accessibilité
bien évidemment c'est extrêmement
important ou alors carrément de ne
mettre aucune action au quel cas ce
bouton n'aurait strictement aucun
intérêt je ne vous le recommande pas
mais voilà on peut venir gratouiller et
customiser alors moi je trouve ça cool
mais je suis un peu frustré pourquoi
parce que par exemple je vais me mettre
sur la lampe torche voyez la torche hop
j'ur appuie plus de torche jour nuit
jour nuit ça vous rappellera peut-être
quelques films un peu ancien donc ça ça
assez marrant mais pour autant ce qui me
frustre c'est que je voudrais pouvoir
faire allez j'appuie trois fois tac j'ai
une action j'appuie quatre fois j'ai une
autre action et là on pourrait vraiment
venir utiliser ce bouton de façon utile
et aujourd'hui il manque vraiment
quelque chose parce que le mode silence
par exemple ça m'intéresse j'ai j'appuie
une fois silence j'appuie deux fois paf
je passe mon sonnerie ensuite par
exemple pour vir déclencher l'appareil
photo ben je voudrais pouvoir venir
appuyer trois fois enfin bref des choses
en nombre d'appuis répété qui aurait un
sens aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
c'est soit une fonction soit une autre
mais pas plusieurs en même temps je
trouve ça un peu con parce que en fait
on se parle uniquement de venir
paramétrer avec un nombre de clics de la
même manière qu'on va faire avec des
écouteurs vous appuyez une fois à
lecture une fois à pause deux fois
morceau suivant trois fois morceau
précédent pourquoi est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas l'avoir ici j'espère qu'ael va venir
le mettre parce que tel quel c'est bien
mais c'est pas suffisant autre sujet
dont on va beaucoup parler sur ces iPhon
bien évidemment c'est l'écran alors on
est chez Apple on a des écrans
extrêmement bien maîtrisés je pas passer
des heures dessus c'est un écran qui est
tellement bien calibré qu'ira vachement
bien extrêmement lumineux donc vous
allez à l'extérieur il y a aucun
problème en plein soleil ça fonctionne
bref très bel écran très bien calibré
film série Netflix Disney plus my canal
ce que vous voulez molotop j'en passe et
des meilleurs ça marche pas de problème
en plus comme l'année dernière on a le
promotion on va de 1 à 120 Hz de une
image sur un always on display jusqu'à
120 images par seconde sur les
expériences de gaming les plus poussées
ok alors Apple va pas chercher à
rajouter de l'aspect pour rajouter de
l'aspect on regarde par exemple si vous
allez chez Moto vous allez avoir un
écran avec un 144 Hz bon ici Apple ne le
fait pas doivent considérer que le 120
Hz suffit largement aujourd'hui ce qui
est vrai voyons clair mais on n pas non
plus de 165 Hz notamment en mode gaming
alors le truc qui est intéressant avec
le gaming c'est que par contre vous avez
beaucoup de performance une nouvelle
puce nouvelle puce qui est intéressante
pourquoi plusieurs choses la première
c'est à ma connaissance et je pense pas
me tromper la première pu qui est gravé
en 3 nanomètres extrêmement fines on
attend l'annonce de Qualcom qui va
arriver d'ici quelques semaines don je
vous reparlerai sur ma chaîne YouTube
donc pensez à vous abonner avec une puce
qui va être je pense aussi gvée en 3
nanomè le Snapdragon 8 Gen 3 ça devrait
être ça son petit nom ici on est sur la
puce A17 pro si vous regardez l'année
dernière on était sur la puce A16 Bionic
on a depuis je crois que c'est depuis
l'iPhone 10 le nom Bionic au niveau des
puces donc aujourd'hui on a la
dénomination pro et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez la gamme
normale iPhone 15 iPhone 15 15 plus et
la gamme Pro iPhone 15 pro iPhone 15 pro
max et là on a une puce qui a un nom
professionnel donc ça veut dire que je
pense on verra l'année prochaine si j'ai
raison que l'année prochaine L iront les
iPhone 16 et 16 plus vous auriez si on
suit ma logique une puce à 17 pas pro
sur les iPhone 16 pro 16 pro max vous
auriez une puce a 18 pro et vous
continueriez à avoir sur les iPhone 15
pro et 15 pro max une puce à 17 pro
est-ce qu'il y aura cette segmentation
ça me paraît assez logique on verra ce
que nous ferale l'année prochaine bien
évidemment pour l'instant ça reste que
la spéculation toujours est-il que cette
nouvelle puce elle est intéressante pour
plusieurs choses déjà en terme de gaming
on va avoir du R Racing mat ça veut dire
que vous allez avoir des lumières vous
allez avoir des ombres magnifiques sur
votre expérience de gaming ils viennent
vraiment faire un gros focus sur le
gaming là où c'est vrai qu'avant on
avait aussi une bonne expérience de
gaming mais là on va aller quand même
vachement plus loin sur ces iPhones ça
c'est bien alors moi il y a un autre
truc que j'ai constaté c'est des petits
problèmes de chauffe lorsque on vient
shooter avec cet iPhone et là vous voyez
celui-là et bien ça chauffe quand même
alors après bon Apple devrait corriger
ce petit problème de chauffe pour qu'on
ne ressente pas mais lorsque vous
l'utiliser aujourd'hui et que vous Shoez
pas mal de choses photos vidéo il a
tendance quand même à chauffer j'espère
que ça va être vraiment amélioré a
priori ça l'autonomie est aussi bonne et
il y a pas de problème là-dessus ça
fonctionne bien après ça va dépendre une
fois plus de vous de vos usages de ce
que vous allez en faire on a une
batterie qui est un poil plus grande par
rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière donc ici bon rien de bien
déconant ça fonctionne sujet qui est
extrêmement intéressant et je vous en
parla il y a quelques jours c'est la
notion qu'avec ces iphonees 15 pro et 15
pro max et bien vous avez une
compatibilité avec un câble en USB 3
c'est l'usbc vous savez l'Europe a
obligé qu'à partir de décembre 2024 et
bien tous les fabriquants de smartphones
sont en usbc sans quoi ils pourront plus
vendre en Europe Apple a pris les de
vendre nous mettant de l'usbc ici il
faut dire qu'il le faisait déjà qu'il
savait le faire avec bien évidemment les
MacBook avec les iPads donc il était
logique de retrouver ici on l'a ici
également et on l'a aussi sur les
airpods le nouvel airpods bon on en
parlera ça probablement un peu plus tard
le sujet qui est intéressant c'est que
sur la gamme pro et bien vous avez une
compatibilité en USB 3 l'USB 3 vous
permet d'avoir des débits jusqu'à 10 GB
par seconde je vous explique tout dans
cette vidéo la différence entre les
iPhone 15 15 plus et 15 Pro 15 pro max
de l'autre côté allez jeter un œil si
vous voulez vraiment tout savoir sur ces
câbles vous allez comprendre la seule
différence que vous vous avez c'est
qu'ici vous avez un câble en USB2 pas en
USB3 attention donc avec le câble qui
est fourni ici on n'ura absolument pas
de vitesse de charge jusqu'à 10 GB par
seconde alors je pense une fois de plus
et je vous dis tout dans ma vidéo vous n
avez pas nécessairement besoin 10 GB par
seconde c'est si vous avez des fichiers
très lourds en terme de vidéo vous avez
besoin de transfert vous avez besoin de
brancher un disque dur externe vous avez
besoin d'un monitoring qui fonctionne
vachement bien notamment une fois de
plus pour les pro mais quand on vous
parle de 10 GB par seconde et duusb 3
vous ne l'avez pas par défaut ici sur
les iPhone pro il faut acheter le câble
avec il vaut de mémoire je crois 79
balles il me semble FO de plus vous dit
tout dans mon autre vidéo toujours
est-il que si vous voulez acheter un
bloc de charge chez Apple ça va être un
bloc de charge 20 W quand Apple a
annoncé ce nouveau usbc en USB 3 j'ai
contacté DX Omark et je leur ai dit
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire vous une
fois que vous aurez les iPhones
qu'est-ce que ça raconte au niveau de la
charge parce que je vous ai déjà
expliqué qu'en fait lorsque vous venez
charger un smartphone avec un câble qui
n'est pas son câble à lui et bien les
vitesses de charge vont être dégradé
pourquoi parce qu'en fait votre
smartphone et votre câble ils vont
communiquer ensemble et si votre
smartphone il reconnaît pas le câble il
va direop hop c'est quoi ce truc est-ce
que ça risque de chauffer est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir un problème auquel cas on
va venir brider la recharge charger
beaucoup moins vite et ça te fera pas
donc j'ai demandé à DxOMark est-ce que
vous pouvez me faire un petit benchmark
regarder ce qu'il en est est-ce que ça
charge bien oui et non et ils m'ont fait
ça merci d x marque alors regardez en
fait ce qu'il nous disent pour l'iPhone
15 pro max si vous prenez ici c'est tout
ce qui va être chargeur officiel donc là
on prend le chargeur de l'iPhone le
chargeur de l'iPad et du MacBook avec un
bloc de charge 20 W 30 W 87 W et bien il
nous disent que de toute façon avec tout
ce qui va être bloc de charge de
l'iPhone on charge en 22 W si vous
prenez un bloc de charge d'un iPad 30 W
et bien vous allez charger en 27 W ça
fonctionne et si si vous prenez un bloc
de charge d'un MacBook ici qui est en 87
W ben vous chargez en 29 W donc bon
c'est maîtrisé ça fonctionne pas de
souci après si vous prenez un chargeur
c'està dire pas le câble mais le bloc de
charge qui est d'une marque différente
en gardant le câble de votre iPhone
c'està direire vous prenez le câble vous
avez dans votre boîte là et que vous
avez un bloc de charge ça peut être
Samsung et compagnie et bien on regarde
ce que ça donne donc là vous mettez au
cul un bloc de charge Samsung en 45 W et
bien vous chargez en 29 W ça fonctionne
celui d'un pixel 30 W 29 W ça marche
onepl 65 W vous charger 29 W Belkin 60 W
vous charger 29 W Anker 65 W vous
chargez en 28 W et force power chargeer
45 W vous chargez en 29 W donc si vous
prenez un C d'iPhone que vous avez livré
avec et vous prenez un bloc de charge
d'une autre marque pas de problème ça
charge bien il y a pas de souci il une
super compatibilité maintenant on va
faire une autre expérience on va venir
prendre un câble d'une notre marque
c'est là où c'est intéressant parce que
votre iPhone va communiquer avec le
câble si se reconnaissent ou se
reconnaissent pas donc on prend le câble
d'un autre marque et on prend ici un
chargeur d'iPad chargeur 30 W et bien on
regarde avec le câble Samsung et le bloc
de charge iPad on charge en 20 7 W et
surt ce que vous preniez un câble
Samsung nothing realme Asus pour le rock
phone Google pixel ou one plus et bien
on recharge partout en 27,6 W aucun
problème ça marche bien et on va encore
plus loin merci Dexo pour les tests vous
prenez un câble Samsung avec un chargeur
SAMSUNG en 45 W ben vous rechargez en 28
W vous prenez un C pixel un chargeur
pixel 30 W vous chargez en 29 W ça
marche C one plus chargeur onepl 65 W ça
charge en 29 W ça marche cap Xiaomi
chargeur Xiaomi 120 W ça recharge en 29
W anur plus son bloc de charge 65 W vous
rechargez en 28 W 29 W force power cable
avec le chargeur 45 W vous rechargez en
29 W donc en fait on voit qu'on aura
même une meilleure charge avec un câble
et un bloc de charge alternatif cohérent
on chargera à peu près en 29 W par
rapport à ce que vous avez en câble
totalement optimisé 20 W chez Apple vous
êtes en 22 W donc dans tous les cas
c'est très cohérent ça marche bien donc
ne vous inquiétez pas si vous avez un
câble d'une autre marque et si vous avez
un bloc de charge d'une autre marque dès
lors que vous êtes pas sur un bloc de
charge 5 ou 10 W soyons clair mais vous
êtes sur du 30 W 60 W 65 W bah ça marche
bien il y a pas de souci ici donc soyez
rassuré et merci DX MAAC pour le test
bon après toute l'expérience logiciel
c'est iOS ici on connait iOS 17 pas de
souci je vous ferai une vidéo pour en
reparler un peu plus tard c'est un petit
peu moins le sujet là on va vraiment se
concentrer sur les nouveautés
matérielles de cet iPhone 15 pro max
alors moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
travail qui sont venus faire du côté de
la photo parce que une fois de plus un
iPhone 14 pro max un iPhone 15 pro max
on se dit c'est la même chose en réalité
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose ils
sont venu vraiment travailler et très
bien travailler la partie photo regardez
vous avez trois capteurs vous aura pas
échapper on a trois c'est bien c'est
beau on comprend le premier capteur
c'est un grand angle de 48 mégapixel on
l'avait déjà l'année dernière ça
fonctionne bien sauf que en fait là où
est venu travailler Apple c'est
intéressant c'est que vous allez avoir
différentes focales à partir de ce 48
mégapixel première chose à savoir c'est
que l'année dernière sur votre 48
mégapixel sur votre iPhone 14 pro max et
bien lorsque vous preniez une photo ça
vous faisait un export avec une photo en
12 mégapixel là cette année par défaut
ça vous sortira une photo en 24
mégapixel ça veut dire qu'on aura quand
même plus de détails ça c'est très très
bien par exemple j'ai cette photo de
Vespa ici alors vous regardez hop là je
viens je monte je zoome et par défaut
ici est écrit 24 mégapixel vous le voyez
alors ça c'est uniquement sur votre
capteur principal grand angle parce que
si vous allez sur l'ultra grand angle
vous allez avoir des photos en 12
mégapixels ça déconne pas c'est normal
mode portrait ça vous fera aussi un
export en 12 mégapixels mais ici voyez
on a quand même un gain qui est
intéressant c'est-à-dire que vous passez
de photo l'année dernière on Sho sur le
48 mégapixel et on est arrivé sur un 12
mégapixel aujourd'hui on shoot sur un 48
mégapixel et on arrive en grandangle sur
un 24 mégapixel ça veut donc dire que
vous aurez plus de détails une meilleure
netteté dans les images et ça c'est
c'est cool et en plus de ça vous avez
trois focales ici 24 28 35 donc vous
choisissez réellement ce que vous voulez
pour venir shooter et vous avez même
lorsque vous venez zoomer là et que vous
allez en X 2 et bien en X 2 en réalité
vous allezê sur le téléobjectif 48
mgapixel on va shooter ici en X 2 en 24
mégapixel et ça fonctionne on vient
croppper numériquement dans l'image sans
dégradation de qualité ça c'est bien
vous avez ensuite votre ultra grand
angle qui est très bien qui fonctionne
ok sur lequel vous allez avoir en plus
et bien de la macro donc vous alle P
venir shooter des petites fleurs des
compagnies ça ok ça fonctionne et puis
là vous êtes carrément sur un
téléobjectif x 5 cette fois-ci un vrai x
5 ça c'est très très cool 120 mm ok on
va regarder les résultat dans quelques
instants sur le papier ça fonctionne le
mode portrait bien évidemment la photo
de nuit votre caméra avant caméra trps
ici qu'on connaît déjà avec face ID pour
venir déverrouiller très rapidement ça
fonctionne c'est mignon c'est sympa
coucou c'est moi on peut venir shooter
en r on n pas obligé pu surtout on a de
la vidéo qui est aussi intéressante où
ils sont venus améliorer les choses
alors bien évidemment on peut venir
shooter en prorz HDR si on le souhaite
ici on vient l'activer ou non pas
comment vous choisissez OK ça marche
mais on peut également venir shooter en
flat ça c'est un nouveau mode qu'on
retrouve ici donc on peut venir shooter
en log pour pouvoir vraiment
retravailler après votre exposition vos
couleurs bref shooter en flat ça c'est
quand même vachement bien bon après il y
a d'autres modes mode ralenti le mode
cinématique qu'on connaissait déjà avant
le mode portrait qui est aussi
intéressant pouvez venir shooter par
exemple faire un focus ici sur
l'appareil faire un focus sur moi avec
votre caméra il y a différents modes de
réglage bon ça ok on connaît un peu
l'histoire on va passer très très
rapidement la vidéo spatiale qui
arrivera à la fin de l'année avec le
casque vision mais ça une fois de plus à
la fin de l'année on en reparlera plus
tard on peut filmer sur en 4K 60 bref
c'est un appareil qui est très
polyvalent et c'est vraiment ce qui nous
intéresse alors maintenant on va
regarder ce que ça raconte quand même en
terme de photos et de vidéo bien
évidemment regardez un peu les images
alors il y a plein de trucs c'est un peu
pmel là on commence par des photos on
est très très proche sur un vest PAP pi
Jo ça c'est le grand tempank grand angle
ultra grand tle petite différence de
colorimétrie on le voit là regardez
lorsque vous passez sur l'ultra grand
angle un côté un peu plus violine qu'on
a pas sur le grand tle un peu plus froid
bon ok on peut venir zoomer dans l'image
si on l'avait expliqué x 2 x 3 x 5 x 10
on va jusqu'à x 25 bien évidemment le X
25 on va éviter la qualité sera pas
forcément là déjà moi ce qui m'intéresse
ici c'est toutes les couleurs qui sont
préservées qui sont très naturelles
c'est très con ce que je vais dire mais
les rouges sont rouges les oranges sont
oranges et les jaunes sont jaunes ça
c'est plutôt bien en venant zoomer on
est sensiblement sur la même chose on
voit une petite différence de colo ici
là voyez entre celle-là et celle-là si
vous regardez je pense que ce sont des
gros poivrons au centre petite
différence ici mais dans l'ensemble le
taf est quand même fait une fois de plus
on vient là grand angle ultra grand
angle ok ça fait le taf et lorsqu'on
vient trop zoomer on va jusqu'au FO 25
le FO 25 il est pas ouf soyons clair ici
si on veut chercher che des smartphones
qui permettent d'aller beaucoup plus
loin on va plus aller voir du côté de
chez Samsung avec notamment un Galaxy
S23 ultra où on pour venir chercher
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'on a là
mais bon on va voir des photos je dirais
jusqu'à un x 5 x 10 ça fera le taf sans
problème voyez c'est pareil l'ultra
grand angle ça fait le taf on vient se
rapprocher très bonne exposition ici au
niveau de l'arbre on peut venir se
rapprocher aussi la Maison du Tourisme à
clairmontferrand bon on évite d'aller
trop près ça fonctionne plus quelques
petites fleurs ici hop là petite fleurs
là comme ça ça fait le taf l'expo est
bonne la cathédrale de ClermontFerrand
où on vient se rapprocher l'expo est
plutôt bonne je va regarder regardez au
niveau ici des façades au niveau des
arbres rien estcramé ça fonctionne tout
est bon bien équilibré bonne gestion ok
bon rien à raconter ici vous prends un J
d' place de Jaud clairement ça c'est
intéressant pourquoi parce que vous
voyez que on a bien le détail partout là
même au niveau des petites gouttes ça
c'est quand même vachement bien ça fait
un vrai arrêt sur image ça fonctionne
super bien on a le ciel qui est là ça
fonctionne bien enfin bref je regarde là
par contre il a une dégradation de la
qualité sur le côté j'ai l'impression
ici c'est très très bizarre la matière
qu'on retrouve ici sur le sol c'est
quand même vachement moins bien alors
après ils viennent travailler avec de
Lia pour vous compenser le contrejour
qu'on a là donc là les bâtiments c'est
pas terrible c'est un peu bruité mais
dans l'ensemble on a quand même une
photo qui est assez équilibrée on va
regarder pourenir se rapprocher là vous
avez le Puil d' on va Leser faire un
gros focus dessus on se rapproche un peu
ça fonctionne il y a un moment on va
perdre un petit peu en qualité voilà ça
c'est le max bon faut-il le faire je
suis pas convaincu là c'est pareil voyez
au niveau des status ça fonctionne bien
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la matière
que je retrouve ici un côté matière
qu'on trouve vraiment au niveau de
l'arbre aussi également lorsque je me
rapprocher ici pareil ça c'est super
bien voyez très net ici on va regarder
maintenant différents photos avec le
mode portrait qui fonctionne super bien
donc ça c'est des photos qui sont posées
qui marchent là le mode portrait qui est
magnifique les petits cheveux derrière
là qui sont un peu plus floutés là par
rapport à là mais ça fait le taf coucou
à auain d'ailleurs là on a des photos en
mouvement ça ça m'intéresse vachement
parce que on est au skate park voyez un
skateer qui est là c'est très net on a
l'impression que c'est posé alors que
non globalement il est en pleine action
là là hop là on a auain qui se jette
c'est parti regardez là au niveau de du
shoot lorsqu'il y a un mouvement ça
fonctionne c'est net il y a aucun
problème ici voyez là c'est pareil la
netteté en mouvement c'est vraiment top
là les photos plus posées ça fonctionne
alors là en venant zoomer par contre sur
du mouvement c'est pas ouf là on va
éviter quand même on perd vraiment
qualité ça se dégrade un coup là
globalement c'est pareil il y a du
mouvement ça se dégrade donc on vient
pas zoomer lorsqu'on est en mouvement
mais lorsqu'on est sur le le grand angle
ça fait le taf mais voyez zoomer c'est
pas ouf là voyez c'est pareil on a
vraiment un flou un flou de Bouget là
qui est pas ouf en zoomant mais là
globalement voyez sans trop zoomer ça
fonctionne vraiment ça ressent bien a M
l'impression que c'estes airpods là il
flash dans l'oreille voyez sans zoomer
tout de suite c'est quand même vachement
mieux au niveau de la qualité le focus
est vraiment fait sur lui là c'est
pareil sur le mouvement voyez tac il est
là il arrive on a l'impression qu'il
bouge pas alors que non ben bien
évidemment il bouge là en l'air c'est
net ça bouge pas c'est calibré ça c'est
vraiment vraiment efficace j'adore cette
photo on a l'impression qu'il est en
suspension que le temps est suspendu
alors que non globalement là il est
complètement en train de sauter c'est
vraiment bien fait ça vraiment vraiment
bien fait alors là on est dans les zones
un peu plus de pénombre lumière
artificielle plutôt bien équilibré ça
fonctionne également on peut venir
zoomer se rapprocher pour regarder en
plus on zoomome bien évidemment on va
récupérer un peu de bruit numérique là
et c'est pas ouf mais sur des plans
larges ça marche avec assez peu de
lumière aussi ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal là au niveau de la gestion des
lumières bon en venant zoomer bon ça
fait le taf on voit qu'ici voyez on
récupère un peu de bordel ici là de la
lumière c'est moins parfait là c'est
pareil je les ai là et je les ai ici bon
voilà ça c'est un peu le petit défaut
qu'on va venir retrouver là d'autres
photos en portrait là qui fonctionnent
également qui sont très très bien là
voyez c'est top avec les lumières du
soir derrière là le visage qui est plus
éclairé là là pour moi c'est top là
c'est pareil vous voyez en se
rapprochant on le prend comme ça là la
lumière sur le visage le contour ça un
peu plus d'ombre ici ça fonctionne
vraiment bien donc le mode portrait de
toute façon chez Apple il est très très
efficace ici là c'est pareil avec je v
pas dire un contrejour parce que c'est
une lumière qui crépuscule mais pour
autant ça fait le taf alors on évite de
trop zoomer parce que là on récupère du
bruit numérique voyez sur l'œil et tout
c'est là où Apple est pas très très bon
c'est quand même sur son zoom ça
mériterait de pouvoir aller beaucoup
plus loin pour venir compenser lorsqu'on
vient zoomer et pas de perdre en qualité
alors ils font un taf là-dessus mais il
y a encore un peu de chemin à faire pour
améliorer quand même la qualité et là on
a beaucoup moins de lumière bon voilà
tout de suite c'est beaucoup plus
difficile on voit qu'en faible
luminosité il y a des moments où il
galère un peu plus l'ultra grand angle
il est au fraise en faible luminosité le
grand angle il fait le taf on évite de
venir zoomer parce qu'on on se perd pas
le meilleur en faible luminosité mais on
peut le faire j'aime bien ce petit côté
bûche feu on vient se rapprocher voyez
là il y a une différence de colo entre
là et là lorsqu'on zoome on peut venir
choper on a quand même un peu de détail
on évite d'aller trop près parce que
déjà d'une on va se brûler pas bon et
puis deux on récupère beaucoup de bruit
donc c'est pas ouf l'appareil lumière
artificielle pizza ça donne faim et ben
on a quand même du détail et ça c'est
assez efficace je do reconnaître
d'ailleurs il y a un truc qui est super
intéressant c'est que le score que nous
donneent des xomar sur leur site web si
on regarde et bien c'est de 154 alors ça
vous parle pas forcément et on s'en fout
un peu mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il est deuxième au positionnement
global derrière le Huawei P60 pro donc
il a un excellent résultat en terme de
photo ça c'est cool alors au-delà de la
photo moi je vrais qu'on regarde aussi
la partie vidéo qui est vraiment
intéressante qui a été shooté avec ce
smartphone donc là hop on est ici
entreut dans un endroit un peu de P
nombre on voit qu'il a un peu plus de
mal avec la gestion de la lumière ici
c'est zoomé donc on perd quand même un
peu en qualité on évite de venir zoomer
avec le smartphone parce que ça fait pas
des masses lorsque vous êtes par contre
sans zoomer en extérieur ça marche
vraiment bien la qualité elle est top
c'est très très très bien stabilisé donc
je trouve ça vraiment super super cool
donc ça c'est vraiment très très bon
point là pareil regardez c'est fluide
c'est net c'est un peu zoomé mais ça
reste quand même relativement bon donc
on évite de trop venir zoomer dedans
parce que ça se dégrade quand même mais
globalement bon le taf est pas trop trop
mal fait là c'est pareil ici ça fait le
taf globalement ça fait le taf moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la fluidité qu'on
va venir avoir ici cette image juste
parce que le vélo a eu peur et que ça me
fait marrer voilà c'est tout sinon
globalement le taf est quand même bon
c'est fluide c'est net c'est dynamique
une fois de plus je vais pas forcément
venir vous vous montrer tout ce qui va
être pouvoir fait en vlog Lorson va
filmer en flat de la même manière je
vous montre pas la vidéo en r parce que
je vais rester plus concentré sur un
Lage grand public on peut aller bien
évidemment plus loin si on vient filmer
en flat en log mais globalement ici
comme c'est fait déjà c'est plutôt pas
mal là c'est pareil à l'intérieur on a
un peu moins de luminosité la gestion de
la lumière est plutôt bonne on peut
venir zoomer un peu on évite de trop
venir zoomer parce qu'après on voit que
la qualité se dégrade mais globalement
comme ça bon le taf est fait on va
regarder également maintenant dans cette
zone avec moins de lumière avec ce feu
derrière bonne gestion au niveau des
flammes ça me paraît quand même plutôt
pas mal c'est assez efficace pareil là
on peut venir zoomer un petit peu on
évite hein mais bon voilà ça reste
dynamique ça reste pas mauvais bon dans
l'ensemble pourquoi pas en fait ce qui
est assez intéressant ici avec ce
smartphone c'est que c'est un vrai petit
couteau suisse le fait d'avoir
différentes focales ça fonctionne bien
le fait de pouvoir venir avoir un usage
plus pro en photo en vidéo en r en log
ça marche ça c'est bien d'avoir ce
format flat c'est cool on est quand même
un peu limité au niveau du zoom on va
pas aussi loin que ce qu'on peut
retrouver avec d're smartphon sur le
marché une fois de plus dans le très
haut de gamme et ça ça reste un poil
frustrant mais pour autant le taf et
fait c'est de bonne qualité bon c'est
très honnête ici après c'est un parti
prix est-ce qu' des fois on va aimer la
teinte un peu plus jeune de votre iPhone
15 pro max ou est-ce qu'on va vouloir
préférer des teintes un peu moins jaune
comme notamment sur un Samsung Galaxy
S23 S23 ultra S23 plus et compagnie
après ce qui m'intéresse c'est que Apple
est venu apporter quand même pas mal de
techno en terme de connectivité a
commencé par du wifi 6e ça c'est
vraiment le truc qui manquait Wii 6
l'année dernière avec un smartphone qui
coûtait très cher je trouvais ça dommage
ça y est ils sont un jour wifi 6e ça
fait le taf Bluetooth 5.3 pour l'audio
pour V Airpod bon ok il y a aucun
problème là-dessus l'audio est aussi
très bien une carte SIM une i SIM la i
SIM c'est bien lorsque vous allez venir
voyager à l'étranger notamment c'est
plutôt cool la détection SOS par
satellite ça c'était déjà un truc
l'année dernière on en a déjà parlé la
détection d'accident également ça c'est
quand même plutôt rassurant on a
également de l'ultra whitede band de 2è
génération donc avec V tag très cool
bien évidemment il est certifié IP68
donc résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
donc ça c'est très très bien également
c'est pas pour autant qu'on va venir le
jeter dans de la flotte mais s'il pleut
ou qu'il tombe dans de l'eau ça va aller
et puis la techn thre pour la domotique
à la maison qui est arrivé ici ça c'est
très très bien également bref c'est un
smartphone que je trouve vraiment
intéressant parce que complet en terme
de visionnage en terme d'écran en terme
de qualité pour venir regarder des films
des séries il est très très bien pour le
gaming il est aussi extrêmement
polyvalent pour la photo il est bon
polyvalent ça pourrait être un peu son
truc la polyvalence il lui manque
quelques petites choses mais dans
l'ensemble c'est une très bonne
expérience alors après c'est un
smartphone qui coûte quand même
relativement cher mais là où je tiens
quand même à saluer l'effort d'Apple
c'est que bien qu'on reste sur un
smartphone très premium très cher bien
ils sont quand même venus faire des
efforts vous regardez sur le site d'
apppple iPhone 15 pro max on voit qu'on
à partir de 1479 € c'est quand même un
certain prix soyons clair alors après
les coloris par défaut titane bleu ok il
y en a d'autres et là vous êtes sur 256
à 1479 €, le 512 1729 € et le interra et
bien c'est le même chiffre que mon année
de naissance 1979 ça reste très cher
soyons clair mais les tarifs sont quand
même à la baisse par rapport à ce qu'on
avait l'année dernière donc ça une fois
de plus c'est vachement bien on est dans
une tendance inflationniste je pense que
ça vous aura pas échappé et on a
toujours tendance à dire que Apple
augmente ses prix augmente ses prix
augmente ses prix augmente S s prix et
bien cette année alors que les tarifs
augmentent de façon générale VO explos
avec une inflation galopante Apple
maîtrise ses prix je trouve ça quand
même vachement bien parce que c'est un
signal important qui est envoyé ici au
consommateur alors attention ça reste
très cher c'est beaucoup d'argent ces
smartphones là ne seront pas destinés à
tout le monde mais il y a quand même un
effort de fait et il fallait le
souligner donc une fois de plus si ces
smartphones vous intéressent bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien juste en
bas dans la description donc moi je suis
plutôt intéressé hypé par ce smartphone
je trouve bien l'expérience de toute
façon iOS 17 reste très bonne et ça
fonctionne une fois plus il y a plein de
choses très intéressantes au niveau de
l'écosystème et c'est un écosystème avec
un Mac une Apple watch des airpods des
tabletts des iPads et compagnie des
AIRTAG donc de toute façon si vous êtes
chez Apple et si vous aimez Apple et si
vous voulez renouveler votre smartphone
la question va plutôt être est-ce que je
prends un iPhone 15 ou est-ce que je
prends un iPhone 15 pro si vous voulez
aller plus loin en terme de photo ça va
être l'iPhone 15 pro mais on va pas y
aller pour l'USB 3 soyons clair après le
titane fait quand même son petit effet
je trouve ça quand même vachement
agréable et c'est globalement un
smartphone que j'aime beaucoup et que je
peux venir recommander s'il vous
intéresse et d'ailleurs un su super
intéressant j'ai fait une vidéo où je
vous compare en photo d'un côté l'iPhone
15 pro max de l'autre côté le Galaxy S23
ultra allez voir cette vidéo vous allez
voir résultat est quand même très
intéressant